[Musique]
bienvenue à cette première émission de
la confrontation c'était en février 2007
l'émission confrontation faisait ses
débuts sur le réseau de l'information a
demandé à trois ex députés des
différents partis qui avaient à québec
de venir débattre de la campagne
jean-pierre des années se sont succédé
et ont fait la part belle à des échanges
parfois musclés mais toujours
respectueux et qui ont séduit les
événements 2012 ont été assez marquant
je pense
cette grève étudiante et c'est ce
printemps érables ça fait pas mal de
flammèches et soit c'est le tai chi qui
va mal à savoir paul la politique et ses
coups qu'on avait de la maison c'était
que les cotes d'écouté at on voit des
personnes âgées qui ont été par le passé
maltraités d'un dessin tu quand on voit
les sommes qui manquent pour marie
grégoire qui a fait douze des treize ans
d'existence de l'émission la joute
politique a bien vite fait partie des
habitudes et pas seulement du public
avec l'arrivée des zecs ça comme un peu
changé à chambouler l'horaire des
policiers qui souvent sont invités à
l'horaire des tour à tour l'émission
présentée par simon du rivage puis
michel viens et enfin jeudi drolet a
évidemment eu un impact sur l'image
publique de ses participants et moi je
dirai tout les années en politique 25
j'ai eu plus de notoriété de
reconnaissance publique à cause de cette
émission l'autre on est tellement
multiculturelle et sur grenade qu'on
s'exprime même au bénéfice des
extraterrestres il veut françois
blanchet qui a fait deux saisons a
quitté pour devenir chef du bloc à
ottawa
il reconnaît que son expérience aux ex
lui a servi une extraordinaire
transition comme l'éducation permanente
ça a été l'apprentissage d'un recul
l'apprentissage d'un ton complètement
différent l'apprentissage de comme un
résumé une idée une analyse après 13 ans
la longévité de cette émission politique
inspire le respect selon liza frulla une
certaine fierté de se dire qu'on a party
quelque chose qui a effectivement fait
sa marque au fait coll
c'est donc la fin d'une époque qui
laisse simon du rivage nostalgique voir
mourir avant son enfance et jamais drôle
voilà je pousse un peu triste toute
l'équipe
merci d'avoir été des nôtres ici
frédéric arnould radio canada montréal
sans avoir bonne fin de journée merci
les ex merci